with hurricane durian bearing down on
the coast of Florida and Georgia
President Trump canceled a planned trip
to Poland so he can stay in the United
States to monitor the storm could call
mr. president some of the left however
are hoping for destruction including
former Canadian Prime Minister Kim
Campbell who tweeted about the storm
quote I'm rooting for a direct hit on
mar-a-lago she later apologized and
deleted the tweet of course joining us
now with the reaction is author of taken
for granted Fox News political analyst
Gianna Caldwell and Trump twenty20
national press secretary Kaley McEnaney
caitli I want to go to you first I mean
on the scale of disgusting does it get
any worse than this I would like to say
no it doesn't get worse than this but I
think it's equally as bad what we see
coming from the left consistently it's
not just the Prime Minister rooting for
devastation a category 4 hurricane
hitting Florida but as you recall you a
Johnny Depp rooting for assassination of
the president Kathy Griffin holding up
the president's head I mean these people
are sick in the head this Prime Minister
this is disgusting but it comes in a
long line in a long pattern of leftist
saying things like I want to blow up the
White House which is what Ashley Judd
said so it's a consistent pattern here
now Giano her justification I mean she
didn't pull it down right away her part
of her justification was that President
Trump's not do enough for climate change
and when he changed the methane rules
now she wants people to be killed and
destroyed and property and destruction
on the United States of America on the
scale of disgusting as I asked Caylee
how do you read this bubonic plague I
mean at this point when considering war
leaders of you know the world leaders
criticize the president all the time we
understand that but is interesting to
see a quote-unquote ally of our country
which death on Americans and this has
become extraordinarily problematic and
what we're seeing especially with Canada
and I think this is indicative of what
we saw with the u.s. MCA they don't like
that we have a president that is
created American first policies and
who's looking out for our country first
and foremost as you all know we have a
trade deficit with Canada and the
billions and we're correcting correcting
that right now and we have a president
who's not going to lay down so I expect
more world leaders are going to
criticize this president but he's going
to continue to he's going to continue to
work for the American people and choose
us first before any other country now
Kayleigh this former prime minister was
one of the shortest terms I think it was
like five months or so I maybe get the
timing wrong discredited I mean she was
one of the worst prime ministers they
ever had I doubt many Americans even
remember who she is but she is working
for Justin Trudeau and she has the the
job right now picking who's going to be
the next I think Supreme Court justice
there in Canada I don't understand how
they do their legal system there but
I've heard nothing from Justin Trudeau
what's your message to the current prime
minister
yeah the current Prime Minister should
chastise her ask for her resignation as
Gianna points out Canada's our ally here
and to have someone sitting in the seat
of government as you noted rooting for
the deaths of people in our country it's
unacceptable language language like this
should have consequences and stepping
down or a resignation is the least of
those consequences that she should
endure and Giano I mean we've heard
people rooting against our economy
because they want the economy to go
south so people would suffer so that
Donald Trump isn't reelected again mr.
Koch passed away you had people cheering
that on as if that was some sort of
there's any sort of justification for
that but how do we call that out how do
we say you know what enough is enough
can we just argue about the actual
policy as opposed to death destruction
and hardship for other people we're
actually doing that right now and you're
on Fox News and I'm thankful that I have
colleagues that continue to call out
this this mess on a day to day basis and
interestingly interestingly enough when
considering the fact that our economy is
the best in my lifetime and it will
continue to be the best you got more
Americans working than ever before you
got seven million job openings and not
enough people to fill them
this president has done a tremendous job
for our economy he's going to continue
to do a tremendous job for our economy
and he's going to call out this nonsense
when it appears and that's one of the
things that I like about President Trump
he's not gonna sit down and take it as
we've seen with other individuals who
have led in his office and that includes
Republicans and Democrats so this is a
new time for us and we're gonna continue
to fight for it because we're not taking
it anymore
listen Canada is our friend it's our
neighbor we love these people and you
know what I've seen hurricanes in the
past come
I remember when Houston happened it was
devastating but you know what I saw
Americans come together it didn't matter
red blue what side of the political
spectrum they all came together and
that's the type of thing knowing that
this hurricane is hitting and
devastating people first to the Bahamas
and then it's coming to to the United
States we pulled together as an American
people and that is that it is a
population here on earth that's the way
at least it should be I thank you both
for joining us Kaylee and Giano thank
you very much appreciate it have a good
holiday weekend